[Música]
primero que nada buenas noches
muchísimas gracias me gustaría empezar
la charla de hoy contándoles
una anécdota primero decirles que me
acaban de develar los colegas pues que
no soy millennial porque nací en el año
80 entonces eso ya me genera una gran
tristeza pero a pesar de que no soy
millennial pues en los años 90
generalmente bueno por lo menos en mi
casa mis dos padres mis padres
trabajaban entonces no había quien me
cuidara y tenía que acompañarlos a hacer
todos los mandados habidos y por haber
esa era la regla en esa época entonces
no habían unos que no me gustaban mucho
pero había uno que particularmente me
dominaba y era que cuando llegábamos al
banco pues yo me sentía que entraba un
sitio muy parecido a éste con unas
lámparas así pero espectaculares o sea
todo lleno de madera pulcro muy elegante
un trato señorial y con distancia y
evidentemente esto a mí me cautivaba
además que estaban las computadoras todo
se movía muy rápido todo en todo momento
y un estrés completo en este entonces
y esto se convirtió en mi cabeza en una
meta en una meta sobre la cual
en el camino de mi vida pues trabajé
duro me formé y me fui construyendo como
ese banquero al que soñaba convertirme
hay una película que también que me
marcó que algunos de ustedes seguramente
vieron que esta película de wall street
donde está a gordon gekko que es ese
banquero despiadado pues ese era el
banquero icónico que tenía yo en mi
mente y a eso me estaba convirtiendo ese
banquero que iba creciendo desde niño y
pasando y convirtiendo mi pasando por
varios bancos y varios países ese
banquero pues especialista en riesgo que
él analytics es su fuerte donde el
cliente se llama costumer y donde
desarrollamos técnicas de costumbre
céntrica a ver cuánto logramos conciliar
a estas personas pero a pesar de todo
este este proceso que estamos llevando
adelante hace 24 meses pues aparece
frente a mí una oportunidad pues inédita
por lo menos para mí como banquero es
como lo más icónico que es dirigir una
organización
una organización de banca que les quiero
presentar en un banco con 53 años de
historia yo con 37 años pues iba a ser
el siguió un más joven de la
organización con más de 70 mil
accionistas con más de 4 mil
trabajadores y un banco posicionado
dentro de los top 5 de ese país un banco
con un futbolín de 156 agencias más o
menos
pero lo particular en todo esto era que
este banco en ese momento estaba pasando
una crisis compleja una crisis desde el
punto de vista de riesgo operacional de
gobernanza que estaba impactando de
forma dramática dentro de su resultado
del negocio
pero evidentemente como el banquero
técnico pues en información de riesgo
esto yo lo vi como una ventana
oportunidad para aplicar todo esas
habilidades y aprendizajes pues que
había agarrado en el camino
pero no solamente la organización per se
se mostraba como un reto sino que además
es una organización que está ubicada en
guatemala guatemala un país como otros
países de latinoamérica con muchas
oportunidades y con muchas diferencias
un país donde 7 de cada 10 personas son
pobres donde hay falta de oportunidades
económicas donde el emprendedurismo
informal es una de las normas que existe
dentro de la economía donde la migración
es una situación
compleja y donde además el país estaba
pasando en ese momento una coyuntura
compleja desde el punto de vista
político entonces todo esto se conjugaba
para hacer un escenario perfecto de
simplemente salir corriendo y decir no
gracias me quedo donde estoy yo no voy a
tomar esa posición pero algo en mi
instinto dijo bueno aquí hay que subirse
en este barco y salir adelante
eso sí solamente hay una sola
oportunidad y swanson
y ahí es donde uno se para como en el
tablero en blanco y prácticamente a ver
bueno cuál es la técnica que mejor me
sirve para utilizar ese en una
estrategia para agarrar todo esto una
crisis de países una crisis de banco
posición primera como si yo entonces
veamos qué es lo que se puede hacer acá
pero fue donde justamente esas preguntas
y ese tablero en blanco llamaron mi
atención y decir mis capacidades no son
suficientes y voy a tener que salir a
escuchar qué es lo que quiere la gente
del banco qué es lo que pretende el
público de esta organización una
organización con 70 mil accionistas
entonces había que salir a escuchar a
los stakeholders no solamente
accionistas sino también a los clientes
a los proveedores a nuestros empleados e
incluso salir a escuchar al mercado a
ver qué pensaba acerca de la industria
bancaria nada más
en guatemala
y ahí entonces empezamos a tener como
resultados
reveladores
qué tal vez algunos creo que como
banqueros seguramente no he escuchado
que el banco lo que hace en dúdar me me
roba el dinero me cobran tasas soy un
número nada más me buscan por mis
inversiones y toda esta cantidad de
cosas que pueden pensar seguramente nada
más de los bancos en guatemala
seguramente aquí en costa rica nadie
piensa así de los bancos ni que les
cobran de manera
pero es simplemente esta percepción de
ese de ese país en el que estamos
posicionados y de la industria en
general que pensaban que esperaba la
persona cerca del banco pues nos
empiezan a hablar de una de cosas que
tal vez no estamos muy acostumbrados que
es de transparencia
de equidad
de conexión
aquí esto es como un poco extraño sobre
todo para uno como banquero que lo que
quiere es maximizar el resultado y el
boro online puedes tener la utilidad
hacer el cross él y pues ya hay
costumbre otra vez a su casa
y aquí es donde pues evidentemente con
todo esto nos chocamos con la realidad y
dijimos bueno si nosotros como
organización financiera
tenemos esa responsabilidad pues
entonces hay que tomar una decisión
si la asumimos o seguimos manteniendo
los ojos cerrados y dejando de sentir y
es ahí donde cabe resaltar que ojos que
ven corazón que no siente
y somos nosotros los banqueros los que
hemos decidido por convicción el no ver
las realidades
en el entorno en el cual nos
desenvolvemos si seguro que la realidad
que les mostré anteriormente no difiere
mucho en los distintos países donde nos
encontramos entonces viendo todo esto
era posible para nosotros avanzar a
diseñar una estrategia dejando por fuera
a todas las personas y sus deseos
pues ahí es donde nosotros decidimos
abrir los ojos y en ese momento pues
empezamos a sentir
entonces fue donde empezamos a pensar
cómo transformar nuestro negocio y fue
donde vimos un punto y aparte y decidir
transformar la forma en que hacemos
negocios
repensar quien estaba en el centro de
nuestro negocio porque si bien es
importante la transformación digital
como la mayoría de mis colegas lo
comentaron antes pues la transformación
digital tiene como centro a la persona y
si esta transformación digital que
ustedes están pensando no les genera
beneficio del ser humano pues déjeme
decirle que va a fracasar de hecho el 70
por ciento de las inversiones que se
realizan en tecnología terminan
fracasando porque no terminan teniendo
un norte claro y el único norte de las
organizaciones financieras debe ser el
generar bienestar a las personas
evidentemente cuando tuvimos esta
iluminación fue donde sentimos que
logramos conectar y lograr hacer
que nuestros ojos vieran y nuestro
corazón sintiera y generar esa conexión
genuina con las personas no solamente
clientes de la organización
sino también nuestros proveedores
nuestros accionistas e incluso personas
interesadas que no tenían ningún nada
que ver con él con el sector financiero
pero evidentemente mover todo esto es es
algo
muy retador es es donde nosotros hacemos
la pregunta y decimos realmente como
organizaciones financieras tenemos que
preocuparnos por lo que sucede dentro de
los países tenemos que actuar
sobre ellos
entonces es ahí donde nace la idea
de formar ecosistemas colaborativos
ecosistemas donde orbitan una cantidad
de elementos como son las empresas
privadas las instituciones públicas
los medios de comunicación los
accionistas los proveedores los
trabajadores de la organización incluso
nuestros clientes hoy día está órbita es
lo que hace que el mundo dejó de ser
piramidal y se volvió plana cualquier
decisión que estamos tomando se conoce
de forma inmediata por lo tanto en el
medio lo que nosotros podemos hacer es
articular y tenemos la capacidad de
articular y todo nuestra capacidad
financiera tiene que ser para articular
el bienestar financiero de todas las
personas
es de ahí en donde vemos esta imagen
donde compartimos la humanidad del ser
humano donde nosotros como organización
financiera nos desvestimos y nos bajamos
de nuestra
olimpo y decidimos ser como todas las
personas decidimos estar al lado de
ellos compartir sus sueños y que ellos
también compartieran nuestros valores
nuestra visión e incluso nuestros miedos
nosotros como organización y como vieron
antes con las preocupaciones que tiene
guatemala desde el punto de vista
educacional pues decidimos avanzar en
una iniciativa de generar una plataforma
de educación financiera que está
presente online y offline es totalmente
gratuita la plataforma incluso para
personas que están fuera de guatemala la
pueden utilizar esta plataforma lo más
interesante porque seguramente todos
ustedes tienen alguna educación
financiera es que ésta fue desarrollada
junto con una universidad guatemala lo
que la hace pedagógicamente adecuada
para cualquier nivel educativo
seguidamente creamos un ecosistema donde
generamos incubadoras de negocios en los
departamentos de más bajos recursos en
los cuales acompañamos a las personas
durante un año a darles educación desde
el punto de vista de emprendedores y con
esto lograr formalizar y no solamente
formalizar sino lograr ecosistemas
económicos y ecosistemas interconectados
donde las personas generan redes
colaborativas entre ellos mismos
entonces esto le genera incluso valor a
las comunidades y al ser humano pero
entonces ahora nos preguntamos toda esta
estrategia y esta inversión en que en
que cae en qué en que termina pues en
primer resultado tener trabajadores
orgullosos de lo que son ideas y de lo
que hacen parte orgullosos de la marca
que acompañan e incluso sentirse
orgullosos porque ésta impacta a la
comunidad en la que ellos viven y a los
suyos
también un vínculo externo donde tenemos
marcas que nos empiezan a reconocer como
una de las marcas más emotivas o de
mayor presencia de mayor reconocimiento
dentro del país e incluso dentro de
centroamérica y además generamos
matrices de opinión positivas de forma
orgánica evidentemente todos los medios
que vimos anteriormente electrónicos
sirven para difundir información
entonces hagamos que esa información
acerca de nosotros sea información real
y que sea información que sea difundida
por nuestros clientes y nuestras
personas interesadas más vale un like
orgánico que las campañas mercadológicas
que podamos hacer
y entrando también en el resultado
cuantitativo porque también ahí se
logran resultados basándonos en esta
estrategia logramos aumentar tres noches
en los últimos tres años en nuestras
calificaciones de fitch lo cual como
ustedes saben muy bien pues resulta en
mejores líneas de financiamiento del
exterior del interior e incluso
localmente una mejor calificación de
riesgos nos ayuda en el encaje legal que
podemos colocar está en el port on line
resulta una mayor utilidad para la
organización
al final del camino pues tenemos una
organización que bajo este esquema ha
venido incrementando su resultado
acumulado en un 14% en los últimos tres
años por lo cual pensar en las personas
y conectar con ellas funciona y
adicionalmente nos agrega valor es por
eso que ojos que ven corazón que siente
muchísimas gracias
[Música]